so
leute kleiner stream aus der reihe bis zum mittagessen also ungefähr eine stunde oder
so ich muss mal übrigens die bitrate hoch stellen weil sonst sieht battlefield 3 richtig kacke aus
das ganze mit macht excellent schein machen die das mit also mal schauen wie das gleich ausschaut
poggers hütsch vielleicht noch ein bisschen hoch so gebe ich mir einen 64 mann server oder
gebe ich mir erst mal 32 mann server ich gebe mir mal 64 mann server scheiß drauf easy das wird
eh grausam 64 mann ist immer asu monkaS nicht sagen massive monkaS was q fuck 5 mann q was
mit den losser dann machen wir eine runde demawentpeak auch ok oder demawentpeak geht immer hallo leute
moin also ich bin bis 13 Uhr ungefähr an so soll ich eine runde battlefield spielen nachdem
ich die letzten wochen quasi fast nur warzone gespielt habe und festgestellt habe das warzone
das game auch nicht wirklich besser macht sondern nur halbwegs erträglich muss ich mal all school
battlefields wobei so all school ist es jetzt ja nicht ist jetzt kein battlefield 1942 oder so
aus bis sie lauter leute ich glaube ist viel zu laut ne viel zu laut viel zu lau noch ein bisschen
da ist er immer noch ein bisschen laut oder auch kann das sein dass man das game gar nicht
sieht moment das game sieht man nicht da muss ich erst mal video fullscreen off back jetzt
jetzt sieht man was ne sieht man was leute doch jetzt sieht man was exzellent
jetzt sieht man wieder nix jetzt sieht man wieder was ok das kann sich nicht so ganz
entscheiden aber was auch immer ihr müsst mal sagen lautstärke bis sie laut oder vermute ich
mal geht zu laut ja denke ich auch glaube auch dass zu laut ist leiser und nintendo musik muss
mal kurz aus was hier los adi die stellzten auf dem dach rum dach stellzer watt wett für 6 alter
huge suppression ist glaube ich immer noch ein ticken lauter wir sind wahrscheinlich
eine runde reingejohnt wo wir gnadenlos auf den sack kriegen ja guter start jetzt muss
die lautstärke halbwegs gehen denke ich sehen wir gleich erst erst mal die runde hier beenden
weil fail direkt squad amok haben wir gebrauchen das ding kann man eigentlich also wenn man
ein halbwegs gutes quad hat na kann man diese base nicht verlieren also es sei denn die gegner sind
halt extrem viel besser was sie wahrscheinlich in dem fall sind aber diese base ist so extrem
schwer einzunehmen das kamer kann man gar nicht verlieren aber ihr werdet wohl aber
werdet gleich sehen wie man es doch verlieren kann spielst du leider aktuell schon ja so jetzt
können die gegner durch jetzt stellst du uns mal hier lang der beste spot das beste spot zu
bringen ist hier immer so bei euch hier beste bester spot excellent spot da kann man nämlich
die leute hier aus der tür rausguckt und vorne weg bashen wenn denn was kommt aber legen wir
schon an einem mini pack hin na erst mal erst mal schön abcampen das ganze ist
wie das das war doch gegner fack warum
auf fack da ist einer kleiner umgekippt was warum steht er auch mit so einem komischen
zum komischen auto darum camp fpsa das ist rush defender was willst du machen
rush defender was da machst du nix vielleicht gehen wir mal also ich hab das gefühl unsere
leute haben es nicht so so wirklich mit die fänden jolo okay hat funktioniert noch mal
schon dreieckig die sandsäcke ich komme gerade vom sport ich weiß es klaut mir keiner aber ich
habe gerade eineinhalb stunden in anführungsstrichen fitness gemacht sport keck w ich weiß eigentlich
keck weight die haben kein bock zu sterben der panzer ich glaube ich sollte engineer ich
glaube ich soll engineer rein join der panzer steht glaube hinter uns und best uns rein
oder vorne ist ja mal davon ist ja monka korona guck mal ich glaube es nicht auch
leute der panzer unser panzer panz man steht davor jetzt wird es echt schwierig
fack hätte funktionieren kann was ist beliebt denn 2020 battlefield 4 auf jeden fall battlefield 4
auf jeden fall battlefield 4 haben wir diffused okay sehr gut sehr gut also die base kann man
eigentlich nicht verlieren wenn man das halbwegs sinnvoll spielt wir wissen ja wie das dass es
nicht so einfach ist ok hier ist schlecht das panz man ok die sind die sind ganz geil auf links
die sind die sind ganz ganz scharf hier auf die linke seite da war doch hier wo ist er
in den kollegen so nicht so nicht guckt euch an ich kann es sich darüber retten die außen
mich wenn ich darüber gehe der hat kein bock mehr meine sense ist komisch komisch eingestellt
gerade ohne hinter uns hinter uns ich muss ja weg auto wir machen jetzt wir machen den
huge play leute massive massive play warum kommt dann ein perfekter panzer
only battlefield leute only battlefield zu geil zu geil so was gibt solche momenten kriegst du
einfach die gibts einfach nur battlefield ich habe sie gar nicht mehr so viel muni ich hoffe
ich hoffe das schneiber tut da oben trifft mich nicht sonst habe ich echt ein problem
ok ich dachte die base kann man kaum verlieren was richtig macht man kann
eine muni brauchen camp fps am start leute oder der panzer also hier ist optimale optimale
pose den holen wir jetzt also ich bin ja nicht ganz selbstlos rübergegangen sondern ja kollege
so nicht hier wirds aber ganz schön voll jetzt gerade hier ist bester spot hier ist
echt bester spot auf der ganzen map wenn man reinkommt sag euch leute bester spot auf
der ganzen map leider gibt es keine ordentlichen rush maps mehr in den in den nächsten battlefields
auch in einem auto das auto fährt durch dass ich das ist schon mal schlecht wenn keiner
mehr hinten ist wir sind ausgestiegen der ist hier durch der ist hier rein ok wir warten
jetzt einfach mal bis die gegner angestellts kommen ok den holen wir nein nein nein nein
lass mich lass mich in ruhe weg weg wir machen jetzt stellts stellts rangestellts da unten
hitten die mich nie da unten hitten die mich nie was die haben gelegt wie haben die das
gemacht wie sind die überhaupt durchgekommen ok ich muss weg weil die kommen gleich von
vorne das ist ja leute ich sag es euch die waren schon an der linken seite am start wir
können hier nicht weg und wenn da einer rauskommt alter lasst euch doch mal blicken oh shit ok
hab ich mal einer geflankt keiner diffuse pepe hans ja mehr als leute killen kann ich nicht
ob wir das squad wechseln nicht das squad die sind die sind eigentlich ganz ok komm
mal her letzten mal mal an 490 ich spiele jetzt erstmal das womit ich klarkommen weil
ich das gelb kaum gespielt habe und mit dem 416 habe ich auf jeden fall am meisten über
ok wir müssen rüber wir müssen rüber ich versuche den kram mal zu diffusen ah shit
da kommt es dann richtig ran zum diffusen hat keine bock aber b ist sau schwer einzunehmen
ja eigentlich man kann das eigentlich kaum verlieren wo sind wo sind der dude what the
fuck wo ist der denn ich blick nicht durch wo sind wir dann ah moment wir sind wir sind
bei uns im spawn die kommen jetzt auch von rechts klein können ich werden die sind immer
ja die sind immer team feed ja aber massive team feed wir sind ja auch an der letzten
wir sind ja quasi an dieser base erst reingejointed vergiss es wir kriegen grad hardcore auf den
sack und da steht der panzer vielleicht können mit unserem panzer ein bisschen ok ich probiers
ich probiers leute ich probiers jolo ich probiers ah shit die stehen links dahinter spawn trap
na auf dem event peak nicht so sehr auf dem event peak ist spawn trap nicht so extrem
denn hier los alter wir stellten uns mal da um die eck er weiß es er weiß es kommt
mit der pistole rum rex beste beste waffe wie lange man kann bettel viel dreimal lange
mit den meisten zuschauen weltweit ja ist ja auch kein kunst kommen machen wir den
den big brain engineer machen wir mal ist hinter uns was ok ich habe dich mal wir haben
wir haben die eigentlich schon gelegt mal dumme frage panzer du bist du gehst in die
falsche richtung naa mit dem ding panz panz mann was ist los jetzt hat er keinen bob mehr
jetzt jetzt jetzt hat er jetzt hat er keine lust mehr hat es gedacht fack steig aus ich
mach nix mehr wann spielst du bett company 2 ich hab die letzten tage mal bett company
2 gespielt so jetzt erste runde mal richtig mit dabei hier ich hab letzten tage mal bett
company 2 gespielt gibt es noch weiß ich auch mal das online sehen kann ich glaube
nicht oder doch der surfer name trump versus putin versus merkel merkel versus mackroff
versus johnson alles klar ja da habe ich jetzt öfters mal drauf gespielt rush noob welcome
das ist übrigens jebait noob welcome das stimmt überhaupt nicht das spiel plus zum
größten halb gute leute desperados 3 nie habe ich mir nicht angeguckt so jetzt erste
richtige runde hier 6464 waren wir auf dem dem event pigoli server anscheinend anscheinend
beste eine der besten rush maps ja huge okay wir haben squad explosives in ist quad ammo
squad cover ist total underrated gewesen so big brain big brain plays von anfang an bock
auf squad klar warum nicht bist du attacker man konnte da nicht drüber hüpfen wir machen
jetzt big brain play ich zeige aber battlefield please wo ging der weg hier noch mal hin man
konnte ja den übelsten big brain weglegen gehen als ohne big brain play excellent
na ich sag doch big brain plays am start wir müssen von hinten gucken dass sie nicht
rankommen sehe gegner big brain play leute ich sags euch massive
weggeschnetzelt hier wie warum stirbt er nicht es ist lebensoppression
wov achtung nein team mate please kill was boosted golf okay ich komme rüber aber aber
nur offene squad weil ansonsten ist kacke kann man richtig spawn squad golf join da
ist er der metal tat san excellent oh wir haben hier die huge huge posi aber wenn wir
nur ein m com kriegen dann erinnert euch dran wer hat's wer hat's wer hat's geholt wer hat's
geholt das m com ha ha ha der blöder blöder pilote da ist der ist richtig fail geflogen
na ja auch fack ich wollte eigentlich minipack schmeißen da ist er monka monka monka monka
s giga das game ist zu easy für max ja wenn man sich die stats anguckt eindeutig guckt
mal da 2k 10 1 easy und sogar gerätzt hier poggers streckt mal deinen kopf raus alter
ich kann nicht raus leute ich kann hier nicht raus auf gar keinen fall kann ich hier raus
wenn ich hier rausgehe bin ich dead dead as fack okay gehen wir rüber gehen wir rüber
gucken wo sie entschärfen wollen ich glaube die haben keinen bock zu zu diffusen hier
gerade 2 easy 2 easy kriegen wir den heli noch mal raus patrick dankeschön für den
zapp ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
so wir machen jetzt nächste aber wir dürfen noch gar nicht ich will den heli rausschießen
bitte kipp heli heli heli heli heli komm her der mag nicht der heli wird geschreckt
der heli mann dann hier noch dankeschön für den zapp der heli mann damit hat er damit
nicht gerechnet ja ich bin mit sich kann sicher wo sie rumstelsen die guten hier den fall
müssen wir hier den den den flank push machen bring ich gehe normalerweise lieber rechts
rum weil rechts kann man in die base stelsen ohne dass es einer checkt lasst mich rein
in die map gatschi bus gatschi bus au au au ich was hier los was ist hier los warum
warum schießt ihr denn auf mich ich finde das nicht fair dass sie dass die zurückschießen
ehrlich gesagt das gehört sich nicht das ich sage euch leute der heli mann der heli
mann will noch mal gehaunt werden von mir achte unten kommt gleich einer rum wenn man
nicht ganz sicher von wurde wo sind sie denn gleich gleich wieder rechts einer am start
sehe schon aber das müssten die eigentlich erwischen ich kann hier gerade nicht weg
ich will ja gar nicht so lange rumsitzen aber was willst du machen heli heli ich sag euch
den heli mann wir kriegen den klein wieder der heli mann nein nein heli mann heli mann
ich dich rausschießen nicht du mich heli mann komm her oh ja ja ja ja heli mann ich
sehe nix ich sehe nix ich muss weg ich hab hier ist mir zu monka s gerade ok ok ok wir
machen den retz train nice midi pack gucken dass rechts nix steht die stehen nämlich
immer ganz gerne auf dem berg au sag mal von wo kommen denn die ganzen nades hier geflogen
ja ist ja mal gut jetzt ok was auch immer hier gerade los ist alter da ist was dran skok
musics aber es fangen nicht wieder alle anzuspielen ok ich mache jetzt mal ein big brain flank
aber die sehen mich wahrscheinlich aber probieren zwar wir probieren zwar big brain flank ich
retz dich erstmal da oben nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein du kannst
du siehst mich gar nicht du siehst mich gar nicht alter du siehst mich gar nicht du siehst
mich gar nicht wo liegt der denn da das ist ja mal total am arsch der welt
ich höre irgendwo unter uns was ach shit kinder kommen jetzt schlecht durch das game
mit nem gescheiten netcode ja es ist teilweise schon ein bisschen fragwürdig wie man getroffen
wird und trifft ja ok jolo jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt achtsung ach shit
oder der heli auch noch man kann nämlich richtig gut rechts in die base in die base rein
ich glaube es spielt jetzt jemand den heli der weiß was er macht das ist ziemlich doof
ok kann ich jetzt nein ich kann meinen flank immer noch nicht machen mit dem heli der heli
ist massiv massiv op jetzt haben wir hier die richtigen krassen movement leute am start
auch guckt euch mal was ist mit den gegnern wieder los die haben nur drauf gewartet dass
jemand das game streamt wahrscheinlich dass jetzt hier wieder mit dem halben klaren rein
können echt zwar irgendwas habs gesehen der heli mann ach so das den kann man damit ja
nicht heilen hier ist ja nur nur nate gespamme ok wie kommen wir hier jetzt rein ich komm
hier nämlich überhaupt nicht weiter also wir kommen hier kein meter vor ein bisschen smoke
vielleicht ich glaube ich nehme jetzt echt so ein heli raus also wenn wir den heli nicht
runterkriegen geht hier nix das ist doch nicht normal wir kommen kein meter vorwärts da machst
du nix wir nehmen die noob jetzt wird runter gestingert klar will der road killen hier
ok so wie ich das sehe komme ich echt nicht vorwärts gerade ja ist klar da ist zu wenig
gepusche der heli typ am anfang ein bisschen smoke wäre auch nicht verkehrt gibt ja leute
die treffen sowas ich hatte es aber schon mal also sobald man sobald man das game streamt
kommen die mega krassen gegner direkt drauf als haben die nur drauf gewartet erste base
ging und jetzt ist hier huge keine chance
echt zwar was links links links ich geier den jetzt mit irgendein stinger runter oder
so aber das kannst du nicht machen der macht das der macht das clever der weiß halt auch
wie man heli fliegt da kannst du eigentlich fast kannst eigentlich fast knicken am besten
war eigentlich rechts rum zu gehen also ist noch zu weit weg hallo spotten gibt's nicht
wird nicht gespottet kann man eigentlich auch die drohen habe ich schon nie ausprobiert
ob man die runter geiern kann den typ treffe ich mit der pg nicht
hallo lasst mich in ruhe ich muss den heli runter geiern
bloß den heli runter geier
ne da kannst du eigentlich nix kurz schaltest dagegen machen der wartet auch wieder bis
du übrigens auch gegen den berg da machst du nix ne hast du keine chance also ja das
so muss das auch machen aber es krass sobald man das game anfängt zu streamen kommen die
ultrakrassen gegner anstarten letztens hier off stream gespielt irgendwie 75 20 oder sonst
was und jetzt ist hier irgendwie übels tryhard mode angesagt die gegner team an level 100
level 100 100 100 100 100abe wo ist die hexe was man braucht genau kannste kannst nichts
Oh wir haben gelegt, Porgas!
Wir haben gelegt, okay ich hoffe die drehen jetzt um und man kann rein.
Okay, okay, okay, gucken wir mal.
Okay, okay Achtung, huge play, warte jetzt ab, ich glaube, ich glaube das war der Weg
hier.
Ich glaube das war der Weg, ich bin mir da nicht ganz sicher.
Habt ihr den big brain flank gesehen Leute?
Alter, wo gings denn hier nochmal rein?
Oh shit, weggeschneiberte!
Aber so geht das, ich hoffe die sind noch dran, wir haben spawn biegen, äh warum kann
ich nicht bei unserem mensch da vorne spawnen, gerry code, warum kann ich nicht bei gerry
code spawnen oder bei ihm hier, warum kann ich nicht bei ihm hier spawnen, was soll das
denn, spawnschneiber gerry code, gerry code ist tot, gerry code, nein gerry code, von
sowas für seit und alles, ich glaube wir haben es gleich, ey haben wir es, huge, massive,
weißt du, okay, gucken wo die dudes rum, rumhampeln, ahhh fast, aber wir haben auch viele tickets,
also man hat es ja an der defense gesehen vorhin, ich glaube ich bin noch nie hier unten durch
gelaufen wirklich, das habe ich, ich kenne gar nicht das gewölbe hier drunter, gucken
wir mal, kann man da rein, lul, was ein glück, dass da gerade so ein typ noch rausgestellt
kommt, hier midi pack, next, so jetzt haben wir helis, ich hole euch leute, ich hole euch,
ich muss aber erstmal hoch, ach nee der ist auf den felsen gefallen, so beste, beste
wech, links, rechts, wir gehen jetzt mal rechts, ganz rechts, oh wir sind ein bisschen früh,
hier ist ein spawn beacon gewesen, hier sitzt einer auf dem berg, wie die wissen wieder,
wo war der, ah hier, oder, aber der rechte flank ist meistens am besten, jetzt only in
battlefield, ja nachdem es in battlefield 3, nachdem es in battlefield 1 und 5 ja irgendwie
6 mal so richtig geile moments gab, muss man halt auch mal wieder das olle ausbuddeln,
aber wo sind die gegner, nichts zu sehen, war da vorne was, ich hole dich, da war noch
mehr, da war noch mehr, exellent, von der seite kommt da was, schauen wir mal hier, ah
der lebt, nee der lebt nicht mehr, was ist denn hier los, alter, ist ja gut, übertreibts
nicht, übertreibts, battlefield please, battlefield, battlefield lasst mich, battlefield, ich hab
ihn gesehen. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Ah, shit. Das ist
der Moment, Piek, ja. Brandenburg-Russ. Okay. Brandenburg-Russ. Der hat eine gute Pose
hier. Excellent. Hab noch mal nix. Okay, big brain, big brain play. Nein, nein, nein,
nein, lass mich in Ruhe. Okay, alle weg anscheinend. What, what, what? Wo ist der? Okay, jetzt
kommt die schwerste Base, Leute. Das ist mit Abstand die schwerste Base, finde ich, auf
der Map, die nächste. Also entweder kriegst du die schnell oder nur mit sehr viel Grind.
Gibt auch keine richtig big brain Wege, die man hier nehmen kann. Guckt, ja, das war doof.
Hätte ich gleich wieder weg. Noch, noch mal, noch mal. Ich komm da raus, ich komm da raus.
Nee, ich komm nicht raus. Aber so viel ist da gar nicht drin. Mit dem Heli von hinten
rein fliegen. Oh ja, das Heli von hinten rein ist tatsächlich huge. Sind wir schon
durch? Gary Cote, Alter. Alter, Gary Cote. Gary, nein. Ich seh nix. Ich seh nix. Hier
ist nix zu sehen. Wir haben schon gearmt? Was ist hier los? Die nehmen Rush ja richtig
ernst. Big brain Rush. Oh, huge flank. Poggers flank. Äh, alles tot, kann das sein? Alles
tot? Lull. Guck mal, ob hier was herkommt. Ich seh nix, Panzman. Jetzt, nee, das war
die schwerste Base auf der ganzen Map. Wobei die letzte auch schwer sein kann, aber es
geht. Also das ist eigentlich die schwerste. Ja, ja, ist gut hier. Will ich abfackeln?
Nicht abfackeln. Abfackeln, unerwünscht. Ok, auf geht's. Let's go, Panzer. Ok, jetzt
gegnerischer Panzer. Ich hab leider, ich bin leider kein Engineer. Das ist das Dove dabei.
Äh, keinen Sinn. Ich kann leider nix machen, Panzer. Alter, Panzer, lass mich vor. Ah,
jetzt, ich will mich jebaiten. You got jebaited. You got jebaited. Je, je, je, je, jebaited.
Je, je, je, je, jebaited. Ok, die Gegner sind gar nicht doof. Normalerweise pushen die immer
wie verrückt. Machen die nicht, was auf der Base auch tödlich ist, wenn das halbe Team
vorne Richtung spawn stirbt. Also die Gegner sind tatsächlich eher medium sized brain anstatt
slow brain. Aber big brain reicht's definitiv noch nicht. Äh. Ok, ich bin jetzt hier.
What? Lull. Ok, ich weiß nicht wo Gegner sind, aber wir chargeen da jetzt einfach rein.
Yolo. Hier ist was drin. Hier ist was drin gewesen. Oder auch nicht. Wow. Wir haben,
wir packen das ja easy. Was ist hier los? Easy win. Soll das Robert Bowling darstellen?
Er hat schon ein bisschen was, ne? Kann eigentlich Battlefield 3 borderless fullscreen? Weil
sonst sieht man ja gar nicht die Emotes. Easy clap. GG. So. Ich überleg grad ob ich nicht
den Server wechsle, weil. Nochmal Damavent Peak. Nochmal Damavent Peak muss nicht sein.
Ich war doch auf dem Damavent Peak. Oder war ich auf dem Rush Classics? Ne, ich war
auf Damavent Peak only, ne? Gucken wir mal. Ah ne, nochmal Damavent Peak muss nicht sein.
Machen wir mal dicht. Und gehen hier mal auf. Rush Classics Sand Crossing. Exzellent. Wobei
ich auch mal Bock hab auf 16 vs 16. Wir probieren mal 16 vs 16 aus. Das ist nicht ganz so chaotisch.
Aber es ist Firestorm. Auf Firestorm hab ich eigentlich auch keinen Bock. Mal gucken wie
weit die Runde ist. Exclusive Fullscreen ist auch deprecated. Was der totaler Schwachsinn
ist, weil das das beste ist, was du eigentlich machen kannst. Mit dieser ganze Windows-Windows-Manager
geduldens rausgeschmissen. So, wie sind die Fender? An welcher Base? Ist das die letzte?
Ne, das ist die erste. Ich bin verwirrt grade. Firestorm, das ist die erste Base, ne? By
the way, unpopuläre Meinung. Unpopuläre Meinung, Firestorm suckt. Ich mag Firestorm
nicht. Kackmap. Der ist tot, hm? Was macht der da? Was macht
der da oben? Ok, der Chat gibt mir recht. Oder auch nicht, geteilter Meinung der Chat.
Ich mag Firestorm nicht. Ich glaub Firestorm ist gut für Leute, die das mögen mit Chats
rumzufliegen. Aber die Runde sollte gleich vorbei sein, wenn sie es jetzt nicht doch
noch irgendwie hinkriegen. Alles klar. Conquest-Map, ja Conquest. Da sitzt er auf dem Silo obendrauf.
Nein, nein, nein Leute, nicht liegen, nicht liegen, please nicht liegen. Ich will, dass
die Runde vorbei ist. Ich hab keinen Bock auf Firestorm. Oh, da kommt links irgendwas,
ne? What the fuck, was ist hier los? Ich hol den Pantsman. Ich glaub die sind... Wo kommt
der her? Einfach mal random so, spawn. Wir retten einfach ein bisschen und gut ist. Was
willst du machen, ne? Hinten fährt der Pantsman rum. Irgendwo rechts liegt ein Schneiber,
der Typ, der mich vorhin weggeschneibert hat. Wir überwachen jetzt einfach B und in 13
Tickets ist die Map vorbei. Moment, da springt was runter. Hallo, game please. Sniper, Sniper.
Wo ist er denn? Sniper. Woah, hab mich nicht gesehen. Da war ich, kein Komrade. Am besten
waren die Sound-Samples, finde ich immer noch in Bad Company 2. Oh, oh, oh. Okay, ich bleib
jetzt einfach hier liegen, easy. Das sind so Sachen, so geile Sachen, wo einfach mal
neben die Enchanted-Chat-Crasht, das gibt's echt nur in Battlefield. Huge Battlefield
Moments. Ey, was soll ich denn hier machen? Ah gut, easy win. Gut. Und jetzt, bless RNG.
Kein Firestorm mehr. Ich will auch Firestorm als Attacker nicht spielen. Ich will was ordentliches.
So, Sand-Crossing, Bazaar, Metro, Demo-Vent-Peak. Na, Demo-Vent-Peak hatten wir ja erst. Steht
die Map nicht im Chat? Ja, man kann den Chat leider im Endscreen nicht mal aufmachen.
Nose-Hair kommt jetzt. Nose-Hair ist auch eine absolut underrated Rush-Map. Nose-Hair. Caspian
Border gefällt mir auch nicht. Caspian Border und Firestorm. So die Maps, wo so die Battlefield-Veteranen
zur damaligen Zeit gesagt haben, oh ja, die einzigen richtigen Battlefield-Maps mag ich
nicht. Och na, komm, mach da. Chat hat mich gebaitet. Chat hat gesagt, es kommt ergeblich
was anderes. Hast du noch Kontakt zu Kaboom? Selten mal, ja. Mal gucken, ob ich noch Panzer
fahren kann. Ich bezweifle es ja, dass ich noch Panzer fahren kann. Äh, Leute, wie hat
man... Secondary? Ah ja, okay. Das wird jetzt echt Fail. Easy, easy. Unser Chat-Mensch
macht das schon, denke ich. Ah, ah, ah. Bam! What? Okay, der hat Glück gehabt. Der hat
echt Glück gehabt, dass er da durchgekommen ist. Huge Glück. Okay, ich kann Panzer fahren
nicht mehr. Ich kann Panzer fahren nicht mehr. Guck mal, wie sehr ich verkacke. Seht
ihr das? Wie krass ich am Verkacken bin. Habt ihr das gesehen? Jutschverkacksohr. Verkack-FPS.
Das ist übrigens quasi nahezu instant death, wenn man hier drauf lang läuft. Aber irgendwie
interessiert es gerade keinen. Weiß ich auch nicht, warum die das nicht interessiert,
dass ich jetzt lang gelaufen bin. Das Spiel sieht immer noch erstaunlich gut aus. Ja,
das ist korrekt. Jut-jut-jut-jut-jup-baited. Jut-jut-jut-jut-jup-baited. Jut-jut-jut-jut-jup-baited.
Oh, turn on hier. MonkaS. Wahnsinn. Manchmal läuft's, ne? Ich leg dir den Midi-Pack. Ah,
du hast schon einen Midi-Pack. Jut-jut-jut-jut-jup-baited. Ah, gehst du weg da oben? Ah, Suppression,
ne? MonkaS-Suppression. Ah, Scheiße von der Seite. Oh, ein Rätsel. Exzellent. Exzellent.
Du wirst jetzt gar nicht so genau von wo. Kann ich dich rätseln? Nein, kann ich nicht.
So, hier oben können sie mich nicht hitten, gescheit. Ich würd euch ja rätseln, ne?
Aber ich komm hier hin. Aha, aha, aha. Och ma, da stehen sie rum, da stehen sie rum.
Da stehen sie einfach rum, ganze Game, auf dem Dach. Oh, nice, was ist denn hier los?
Oh, what? Crown, bist du aus dem Stream? Du warst ja auch im letzten Setzen-Server da,
das ist ja nice. THX. Nicer Support. Ist nix zu meckern. Aha, so geht's nicht hier.
Sterben, please. Sterben, please. Oh, oh, die, ne, die saß. Das war gut hier. Dass
der die da von unten getroffen hat, ich hab grad das liegt. Moment, was? Bad luck? Bad,
bad luck? Okay, Moment, an was bin ich genau gestorben? An, an was? Kann mir das jemand
erklären? Nice, danke. Kann mir das irgendjemand erklären, woran ich grade gestorben bin?
Gestolpert, ja. Ich glaub's auch. Monka, stolpert. Okay, wir müssen gucken, dass sie nicht diffusen
können. Ich, ich, ich, ich aim das jetzt hier einfach. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Ah, wir haben
die Base. Exzellent. Manchmal versteht man die Battlefield-Logik nicht, ne? Okay. Nein,
nein, nein, Panzer, Panzer, Panzer wegbleiben. Panzer, gehst du fort. War da oben was? Oh,
der ist so low. Ein Hit noch, dann wär er down gewesen. Na, scheiß drauf, wir gehen
einfach. Let's go. By the way, das ist normale Ticketanzahl. Nein, das ist normale Ticketanzahl.
Was, der Panzer kann dich nicht sehen, wenn du dich nicht bewegst. Das ist so wie, so
wie der T-Rex aus Jurassic Park, oder wie? Oh, der geht ab hier, Mauskrone. Oh, oh, oh.
TKX. Okay, ich camp das jetzt hier mal ab. Na, ey, what? What? Das glaub ich jetzt nicht,
dass es, dass es ein Jet war, der mich da drin aus der Mauer, ey, ist klar, ey, Alter,
ey, ist klar, Leute, ist natürlich, natürlich. Streamsniper. Aber meine Teammates sind ja
übelst big brain, also die gehen ja voll ab. Die sind huge. Okay, ich blicke hier nicht
durch, was hier passiert gerade. Ich möchte einfach nur, Battlefield, ich will einfach
nur durchs Fenster springen. Kann ich dich retzen? Ich guck mal, ob ich den holen kann.
Der ist draußen. Oh nein. Ah, Battlefield. Nein, der ist drin. Nein. Ich hab's versucht.
Ich hab's versucht. Oh, da waren Gegner. Noch mehr Gegner. Okay, jetzt big brain flank.
Huge, massive flank. What the? Ah, gibt's ja net. Sauerei. Hätte ich mich vielleicht
vorher mal heilen sollen. Haben wir die, die Base haben wir auch schon. Mein Team ist,
ist, also die sind ja, die sind ja Poggers. Poggers, Koggers, Zoggers, Alter. Die gehen
ja hier durch wie nix. Okay, let's go. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh. Jetzt Pusherino. Oh, da kommt einfach mal, einfach mal Panzer.
Ohohoho hemisphere fill the Facebook
Ist ich frage mich grade war es in battlefile 3 nicht auch so dass man schneller gelaufen ist wenn man den den dv
2 introduces cool earnımote 4 dabei hatte
Alles klar
Also in Bad Company 2 bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, dass man schneller gelaufen ist, wenn
man den Defi draus hatte.
Mit Pistol, mit, in dem Game, ich bin mir nicht sicher ob mit Pistol, nee ich glaub
das machte keinen Unterschied.
Aber ich glaub mit, mit Defi ist man ein Ticken schneller.
Das bilde ich mir zumindest ein.
Aber wie viele da oben sind?
Links?
Ah!
Die holen wir jetzt, die werden jetzt geschreckt.
Next, okay den holen wir, oh da war ein Gegner, haha Noob Gegner alter, oh, oh, oh, oh, ooooh!
Was mit den Gegnern los, wollen die sich grad von mir erschrecken lassen oder was?
Denken die sich, oh da Max der muss mich mal bashen, ich hab da schon seit 5 Jahren drauf
gewartet, dass der, dass der Max mich bashet, anders kann ich mir das grad nicht erklären
was mit den Gegnern los ist.
Ah, shit, shit, shit, shit, nice, Monka ist, das ist ja anstrengend grad, letzte Base,
können sie es mal wieder voll wissen, oh Leute gleich gibt es Mittagessen, dann ist der Spaß
schon wieder vorbei.
Äh, alles klar Battlefield, alles klar, alles klar.
So ein geiler Panz-Panz-Man wäre gut, so ein geiler Panz-Man-Fahrer, streck deinen Kopf
raus, streck deinen Kopf raus, Kopf, please, Kopf, Kopf, okay, dann gehen wir mal.
Wo, wo, wo, wo war der denn jetzt, ich hab nix gesehen, habt ihr den gesehen, wir haben
alles gecheckt, jede Ecke aber nix da, war der ganz in der Ecke, kann das sein, dass
der komplett, ganz, ganz in der Ecke war, oh ich kann da jetzt nicht hin, oh shit, okay
ich bleib liegen, ihr könnt bei mir spawnen Leute, wenn ihr wollt, Alter, Alter, ich kann
da nicht vor, ich krieg auf den Sack, wenn ich da vorgehe, ich krieg huge auf den Sack,
nein, lasst ihr mich in Ruhe, ihr Kackschneiber, Kackschneibers, geht ihr fort, das war unfair,
ich hab den durch die Wand gesehen, Alter, jetzt geht er ab, jetzt geht er ab, volle
Purle, volle Purle, ran, ran, ran, ran, ran, ran, ran, run lege henne, lege henne, du L embarrassed,
nein ich wollt gerade um die Ecke, die werdenDe, die kriegen gerade echt auf den Sack.
MonkaS hier, was ist hier los? Drei Spieler haben Gegner direkt vor einem
Was ist mit den Gegnern los, Alter?
Füße, Füße, ich seh Gegner Füße und ich seh Panzer
Easy easy easy, man muss sagen ich hab auch ein saumäßig gutes Team, ne? Also GG, Teams
Team, Teams, Teams mit Z. So eine Runde können wir vielleicht noch machen,
danach muss ich essen, je nachdem was essen kommt. Döner-Pide-Lammer-Jun
Nee, was erzähl ich für'n Schwachsinn, das hab ich gestern gegessen. Big Brain, Alter.
Jetzt hab ich Frikadellen mit Kartoffeln gibt's heute. Wenn das Game schon dein
Hirn komplett kaputt macht. Döner-Pide-Lammer-Jun war gestern, heute ist Kartoffeln mit
Frikadellen. Fünf Kopf, ja. Eigentlich schon, eigentlich schon sechs Kopf.
Eigentlich ist das war das schon eher so. Übrigens, ich muss mal schauen, ich hab
nichts mitgekriegt im Chat, auch keine Subscri- Och nee, please, jetzt nicht so ne Kackmap noch
hinten drauf. Ich weiß unpopuläre Meinung, ja. Ähm, ich glaub ich hab nix
übersehen. Tribulan hat subscribt, acht Monate dankeschön.
Exzellent. Schwellst du immer, essen oder kocht wer für dich, mal so, mal so. Mal so,
mal so. Na gut, dann spielen wir jetzt halt nochmal ne Runde Caspian Border. Wie hieß das Ding auf
deutsch? War das Kaspische Grenze? Haben sie es so normal übersetzt? Einfach mal auf den Heli
sprayen, weil man hittet schon mal was. Moment, der Heli ist da hinten abgestiegen, die kommen
hier klar um die Ecke. Nee, der ist gestorben. Der Heli ist gestorben. Oder sind die hier,
ich seh nix. Da bin ich mir jetzt nicht so ganz sicher. Oh, da kommt ein Panzer und ein Auto.
Oder auch nicht. Ah, Moment, wo... Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, ich war weg Gegner, ich war noch weg.
Habe ich auch mal gesagt, dass ich die Map nicht mag?
Lull
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, ich habe Schiss leider
Moment, dass ich da überhaupt was hitte, ich, ich spraye einfach random auf Gegner drauf
äh, nope, jop, den Rest kriege ich leider nicht mehr raus, jetzt kannste knicken
Panzer, hoffentlich sprengt er nicht das Ding hier in die Luft
Hallo ich will dich markieren Tank
Okay, nein, ist nicht, ist nicht erlaubt, ich darf ihn nicht retzen, nicht mal Warzone,
ja, ja, Warzone, ich hab die letzten Wochen Warzone gespielt und ich muss mal wieder
was spielen, wo ich normal, wo ich mich nicht über das Game aufrege.
Oh, die sind an A, A, A, A, A und hinter uns auch, der Heli Mann, steht hier hinten
einer, nein, nein, bewegen, bewegen, bewegen, bewegen, bewegen, bewegen, oh, das war knapp
Monka S, aber, aber, richtig Monka Giga war das, Monka Giga Deluxe, der Heli Mann, der
Heli Mann ist nervig, aber alle Heli-Mans sind nervig in Battlefield, also vor allem Heli-Mans,
die wissen, Heli-Mans, die wissen was sie machen, Heli-Mans, okay, ich bleib jetzt einfach
hier sitzen.
Übrigens, Defender wird, äh, retzen total underrated, die sagen, ja, du hast ja endlich
Tickets zum Respawn, aber das war noch kein Battlefield, so, gerade als Defender bist
du darauf angewiesen, dass du am Objective bist, wenn was ist und nicht erst drei Kilometer
laufen musst, also auch wenn du keine Tickets hast, weil natürlich ist bei, ist als Attacker
auch wichtig, dass man, dass man, what the hell ist hier los, ey, ich weiß nicht von
wo hier was ist, ich hab echt keinen Plan, aber mein Team macht das schon, Team ist gut,
sagt man selten in Battlefield, ich weiß, oh nice, guckt mal, ich wäre sogar gerätzt,
guckt euch das mal an, nein, ja aber leider nicht lang, elef77, weil gleich ist Essen
da, da muss ich, muss ich auf, ich hätte ja gern noch mal eine Map gespielt, auf die
ich Bock hab, ach, wir haben die Fused, exellent, und wir smokeen uns ein, auch gut, erstmal
in, in, irgendwo, irgendwo in die Luft spotten und gucken, ob was abgeht, drüben geht auch
nix, oh Jett, Jett, nix wie weg, ok mal gucken, ob wir die irgendwie geflankt kriegen, alter,
was ist hier, übertreibt es halt, so Sachen hatte ich in Battlefield 1 und Battlefield
5 nie, wo du so wirklich gedacht hast, was ist denn hier los, um nicht drum herum, ich,
ich mache jetzt übrigens hier die, die, die runtergeier Deluxe Geschichte, ok oder auch
nicht, runtergeiern Deluxe machen wir jetzt, erstmal verstecken bis er vorbei ist, jetzt
runtergeiern Deluxe, hallo, Flairs geht weg, das Ding hatte nicht so eine große Range ne,
ich spiele selten, ich kenne die Range nicht, die Range nicht, hallo, hallo, jetzt, oh nee,
jetzt hat er auch geflährt, oh, oh, oh, oh, bam, null, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, ich mag
die Map nicht, wir haben es verloren, ich glaube es nicht, Jett, Jett, Jett, Jett, Jett, Jett,
ich bin gebadet, Maxi spielt dieses Game immer noch geil, du kannst nichts sagen, der wird
jetzt einfach klanlos runtergegeiert, ok, Game, alles klar, wenn es nicht trifft, dann
Lul, ha ha, oh, oh, oh, die Waffe macht keinen Damage.
Ah, ich wollte mir, ich wollte mir das Medikit holen von dem ohne Wiederbeleben.
Oh, das ist ein bisschen viel. Vielleicht sollte ich die Engineer-Geschichte doch sein lassen
und das spielen, was ich kann. Und Bashen.
Das ist die schlechte, ja die ist Kacke. Aber ich mag halt die MP5 an sich und deswegen,
deswegen spiele ich die ganz gern, aber die sackt auch richtig. M4 beim Engineer ist beispielsweise
echt zu gebrauchen.
Battlefield 3 Remake Gerüchte. Ich vermute ja wirklich, dass da was dran ist. Ich weiß
aber nicht, ob es wirklich ein Battlefield 3 wird, weil die müssen die Zeit überbrücken
bis Battlefield 6. Den bleibt nichts anderes übrig. Die haben Battlefield 5 viel zu früh
abgesägt, also viel früher als sie letztendlich vorhatten.
Was ist denn das? Ah, die Drohnen-Stells. Viel früher als sie eigentlich vorhatten
und dementsprechend. Was? What? Wie haben die das denn jetzt so schnell gekriegt?
Konnte man das Haus kaputt machen, wo das Objective drin war? Das dachte, das ging nur
in Bad Company 2. Oh, rechts war noch einer. Ob der Down ist da rechts? Hoffe ich mal.
Anscheinend, ich kriege nichts gespottet. Deswegen glaube ich, die Chance, dass wir
einen Remaster Battlefield kriegen Ende des Jahres, ist gar nicht mal so gering. Ist der
Dude auf dem Dach? What the fuck? Ich bin aber trotzdem der Meinung, Battlefield 3 braucht
kein Remaster. Ich meine, wozu braucht das Game ein Remaster? Ist doch alles da. Ich
checke nicht, wo die Gegner gerade sind. Das ist wirklich kein Big Brain Plays von den
Gegnern. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo irgendwas abgeht. Geiler ist, die anderen sehen die
nicht. Besserer Netcode. Ich mag das eigentlich, ich finde das eigentlich ganz gut. Du hast
halt das Problem manchmal, ja das stimmt schon, dass die Leute halt, was ist denn hier los
da? Durchfliegen, ja, oder durch. Hinter uns, hinter uns, hinter uns. Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Na fuck, ich hätte ihn fast erwischt. Fast hätte ich ihn gehabt noch. Habt ihr das gesehen?
Ganz knappe Geschichte. Ja, Xbox stimmt, auf der Xbox kannst du natürlich nicht spielen.
Die 360 Variante kannst du knicken. Habe ich schon mal gesagt, außer die letzten 20
mal, in den letzten 5 Minuten, dass ich die Map nicht mag? Ich sag's nochmal, ich mag
keine
Wir verpissen uns mal hier kurz.
Oh ne, gemessert, da wird er gemessert.
Ja das, wenn die nur den Singleplayer remastern, wäre das mal absolut Lowbrainer, richtig Lowbrainer.
Ich glaub die sind schon am Start hier teilweise.
Ja, im Teppichmesser.
So wie sie es in MW2 gemacht haben, erstmal Singleplayer remastern.
Wahrscheinlich weil es der geringste Aufwand war, keine Ahnung.
Hab ich da grad Gegner gesehen auf der Map rechts außen?
Kann das sein?
Kann das sein, dass ich da Gegner sehe?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, ach mann, warum, den hätte ich jetzt erwischen, der geht jetzt
legen, der macht jetzt lege Henne.
Oh, excellent, excellent, ok ich komm mit vor, das Sounds Master, das Saurus, das Saurus
Master, nicht das Saurus, Saurus.
Truckus Saurus Rex, kennt das noch jemand aus der World Company 2 Kampagne, diesen Monster
Truck?
Der Truckus, oh meine Güte ey, der Truckus Saurus Rex, ok Leute, die machen uns, die
machen uns platt, jetzt ist die Munition alle, jetzt ist die Munition alle, oh, oh, what,
ok, alles klar, ja, Map, please, ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob das Essen fertig ist, bin
ich gleich wieder am Start, so, Essen ist noch nicht am Start, ich muss mal kurz gucken,
ob das Essen fertig ist, ich muss mal kurz schauen, ob das Essen fertig ist, ich muss
kurze sache die runden waren aber trotzdem cool auch wenn wir zwei maps
gespielt haben auf die ich überhaupt keinen bock hatte
firestorm und claspion border die nervigsten maps überhaupt für mich
mal gucken vielleicht spielen wir nachher weiter bis denn cu machts gut